the top donkeys met last night for a
town-hall scheduled at the last minute
before the Iowa caucuses didn't catch it
no problem because we burn through the
bull to bring you everything you need to
know in 90 seconds first up Bernie
Sanders or BS he was full of promises
ranging from the inadvisable to the
impossible we should expand Social
Security providing paid family and
medical leave to all of our people I
believe that every kid in this country
should be able to get a higher education
just one catch to pay for this estimated
18 trillion dollars in additional
spending Sanders has two options debts
mother your children or we will raise
taxes and there it is while Bernie was
eating his free lunch martin O'Malley
happened to wander into the room and got
himself settled touting his record
O'Malley shifted to local politics after
all from nineteen ninety nine to two
thousand seven he was the mayor of that
shining city on the hill Baltimore there
are a lot of things we got right there
were a lot of lives that we saved I'm
the first candidate in either party to
put forward a new agenda for America's
cities when very few other people would
step up who could bring us together and
turn it around I did so how is this
model for the modern gun controlled City
doing today well last year saw the
highest per capita murder rate in
history and a near record number of
shootings progress and finally emerging
from the fog of classified email was the
most relatable version of Hillary
Clinton we've seen yet okay maybe not
you're willing to say it was an error in
judgment you should have apologized I'm
not willing to say it was Erin judgment
because what nothing that I did was
wrong while Russian and Chinese hackers
sure do appreciate her transparency a
hundred FBI agents and countless Libyan
civilians might beg to differ but don't
worry America that's not a huge spider
eating Hillary Clinton's neck it's just
a stupidly large microphone and that's
really all we got from the Democratic
Town Hall